morning all plenty to get on with this
morning but before we do breaking news
uh on the state of the uk economy now
and the cost of living crisis uh let's
speak now to our economics editor ed
conway at joining us at through the
screen are you doing this morning ed
explain exactly what these figures are
and what we're learning
yeah i'm afraid it's quite uh bad news
the uh we were due to get the state of
the economy gross domestic products and
how much it's expanding or contracting
by this is the best measure of just how
well we are doing you know it's a
measure of how much income is being
generated across the economy uh the
previous month which is say march those
are the previous figures we had showed a
contraction of 0.1 percent well the
latest figures show a contraction of 0.3
let me just show it to you
on this chart here here you can see it
there was minus 0.1 percent in march uh
in april it's down by 0.3
percent so a contraction it's actually
worse than economists had expected they
thought that perhaps it might be a
little bit of an increase but this just
underlines those concerns a lot of
people have that the economy might now
be heading towards if not a recession
then certainly a period of contraction
or stagnation remember the oecd the that
big organization uh looking at economics
they said that the uk would face the
weakest growth in any developed economy
next year and might face a potential
period of basically flatlining well this
is showing that we're already seeing uh
some fall in the amount of income we're
generating across the economy and
economists will be concerned about it
because obviously it comes amid many
concerns about the cost of living it
comes with households being severely
pressed uh by higher costs of energy and
of course with businesses across the
country struggling uh to satisfy uh to
try and actually kind of generate the
demand they that they need to try and
keep this bounce back in the economy
going so that is a cause for genuine
concern the numbers just out from the
office for national statistics and as i
say worse than expected there have been
an expectation that the economy would uh
actually expand in the month of april
but these monthly numbers suggesting
that it contracted by 0.3 and as you can
see it is the biggest contraction it
looks like since
uh december in terms of monthly uh
numbers for gdp so a bit of a
disappointment there
to to to put it mildly edge so what then
are the tools at the treasury's disposal
at the prime minister's disposal to try
and do something about this in the short
term
well i mean in short you know the the
government has already
put a lot of uh fuel in there they have
announced that they are going to be uh
subsidizing energy bills to the tune of
400 pounds that's obviously coming on uh
later in uh in the year uh they've also
uh
produced extra money that's going into
people's council taxes as well so you've
you have government stimulus coming
through
but the reality is there is a big
fall-off in demand at the moment and
it's it's it's a uk story in particular
uh but to some extent we are seeing
something like this elsewhere around the
world
as well many other economies are
starting to weaken perhaps not
necessarily as as quickly as the uk
but nonetheless you're seeing the same
thing and why is this it's because we
have a massive energy price shock right
now energy prices have gone through the
roof and as a result of that that's
something that we will notice obviously
in our household bills but companies
around the country notice it as well
because everyone has to one way or
another pay for energy and that is
basically causing or helping contributes
uh to this you've had really strong
growth uh just last year uh in these
months last year but now look at the
where we are at the moment two con
successive months uh worth of
contraction it's not quite in recession
territory uh yet because we need to
actually get the quarterly numbers so
when people talk about recessions they
tend to mean two successive quarters of
contraction we're talking about months
so we're yet to get the rest of the
months uh in the current quarter we're
in at the moment we need a couple more
months for that but if that continues
obviously then we're talking about a
quarter
of contraction and then that's one step
closer to a recession one just a little
bit of detail because this is data
that's just come in literally a few
minutes ago
in terms of what's contributing to it
services so that's the main part of the
economy 80 percent uh that is the main
thing falling by 0.3 but we'll bring you
more data and more detail on this uh as
we have it as i say disappointing news
that the economy uh is falling at the
moment ed thanks very much indeed uh
clearly a big day in terms of the
economy a big day also in terms of
northern ireland what will it take to
get stormic back up and running today we
will have perhaps the first idea of how
the government
is going to deal with the problems as
identified by them with the withdrawal
agreement with the protocol here's our
correspondent stephen murphy
if you want to know who's doing the
heavy lifting on the protocol you should
speak to a haulage firm and its staff
grappling with a surge in red tape the
protocol hurts our customers
and it hurts our customers moving goods
between britain and northern ireland for
peter new legislation from london could
offer some hope it's essential that
something is done to ease the complex
movements that happen between great
britain and northern ireland and the
current position does not address those
problems it's expected the government's
bill will contain provisions to
effectively abolish the controversial
irish sea customs checks the eu will see
that as a breach of law not so according
to the northern ireland secretary we as
a government will be outlining our legal
position and being very clear about why
this is absolutely within the law that
earned him this repulsed from sinn
fein's leader brandon lewis is talking
through his hat and not for the first
time the british government has refused
to engage
has not been constructive has sought a
destructive path and is now proposing to
introduce legislation that will
undoubtedly breach international law of
course there are also sectors here that
see the protocol is offering them
shelter from the brexit economic
downpour offering companies unfettered
access both to the uk market and the
european market of 440 million consumers
an advantage enjoyed nowhere else in the
united kingdom
to them new legislation risks upsetting
that arrangement scrapping of checks
would be welcomed by many but the
concern then will be potential economic
countermeasures by brussels
stephen murphy sky news in belfast
it is only monday but already there are
two big rows set to gather a bit of
steam today one over plans to send
asylum seekers to rwanda the other
overpost brexit trade arrangements and
of course we've just had those gdp
figures dropping in the past couple of
minutes very pleased to say uh we've hit
the laptop uh with the hammer and the
environment secretary george eustis
joins us now on the program good to see
you mr eustace um i wonder if we could
start with those gdp figures obviously
they have now dropped but a contraction
of 0.3
not what people were expecting certainly
not what people were wanting is it now
time for the government to stop
maintaining that this is the fastest
growing economy in the g7
well the truth is that as we all come
out of the pandemic globally there are
pressures on supply chains and a lot of
inflationary pressure around the world
principally of course caused by that
spike in the gas price so we've known
for some time that this is going to be a
challenge but it doesn't take away from
the fact that actually we were
successful at getting ourselves through
the pandemic the fastest vaccine roll
out and that put our economy in a strong
position to recover we've got
unemployment that's at record lows the
lowest it's been since at least 1974 but
of course there are some real challenges
ahead and these gdp figures of course
are a reminder of those challenges
um let's talk then on one of the major
political political issues of the day
and i promise we will come on to the
announcement on your brief in a moment
that the northern ireland protocol at
the government tabling the bill today to
try and solve some of the problems with
it can you explain to me and indeed to
joshua rosenberg at the legal the legal
commentator how you can break an
international agreement the arrangement
that we have with the european union in
the form of the protocol and it not be a
breach of international law
well look obviously when the bill is
introduced we'll set out the legal you
know basis for that and the attorney
general has uh has been involved closely
with this and has uh given you know
given her advice on it but the the
crucial thing is the import we have we
have to make this northern ireland
protocol work properly because at the
moment it's a it's a serious threat to
the belfast good friday agreement and
you know we don't have the
inter-ministerial committees meeting
which is supposed to bring together
politicians on both sides of the irish
border stormont's uh not sitting and
trade from gb to northern ireland has
been severely affected so we have to get
a durable solution to this we've been
trying very hard with the european union
to get them to discuss they're refusing
to even change their mandate and so we
have to basically give clarity
about what the protocol means how it
should be interpreted only the uk can do
that
but just in terms of of the action that
you're taking today do you not accept
the fact that everyone wants torment to
be back up and running as soon as
possible but do you not accept the fact
that given that a majority of the
assembly members that would be sitting
at storm want do not want you to take
this action that actually think that you
know business in northern ireland has
got to grips the protocol in what way is
that democratic
well actually um brandon lewis has been
working with politicians uh right across
uh ireland and all of the parties and
they all recognize that if the protocol
were to be fully uh implemented it
really wouldn't work and you know you
say that people are grappling with it
have gotten used to it it's important to
recognize that most of the provisions
aren't yet being implemented so there
are some standstill provisions that we
have which means we're not actually
doing any checks at the moment uh when
it comes to um
products going from gb to to northern
ireland there are many other grace
periods that are only temporary and what
we need is some longer-term permanent
solutions and that's what this bill
would set out
so so how's the have the dup committed
then on the basis of the bill that will
be tabled later on today to return to
power sharing
and my understanding is that they
haven't but obviously there's a parallel
set of discussions there we very much
want them to uh to get back to power
sharing they're very clear they want to
see um you know some progress made and
that we at least get this bill
introduced and started but i know we'll
obviously be working very hard
to get them back in place they want to
see the issues around the protocol
settled and that's what this
government's determined to do
i i do want to ask a little bit about
the the cbi an organization which is
which has made a number of comments
about the northern ireland protocol over
uh well over the course of its lifetime
and tony danker has been accused of
interfering in the government's plans to
deal with the protocol a couple of your
colleagues briefing the papers along
those lines do you share that view do
you think the cbi should you know sit
down and shut up
well look i work um very closely with
lots of different businesses and the
truth is that most of the major
retailers like marks and spencers and
tesco and others who are sending quite
complex composite loads of loras to
northern ireland they know that the
protocol if implemented in its in its um
uh full way wouldn't it wouldn't allow
their business models to really continue
so uh businesses generally do want us to
sort this problem out obviously cbi's
and lobby group it can it can set out
its position um but we've obviously
got access to the sort of right legal
advice as to what we're doing and we
obviously have a much more knowledge and
we we draw um we draw a comment from a
much wider pool of businesses than the
cbi represents
the rwanda repatriation flights again
heading towards the court of appeal
today it seems likely there will be some
form of legal action you know over the
coming weeks and months in terms of all
of this and one question that keeps
getting it keeps coming up to me is why
haven't you legislated to allow the
government to do this why have you not
legislated you know passed a bill that
for example you said ignore these parts
of the human rights act ignore these
parts of the modern slavery act and move
forward i mean you've got the majority
to do it so i i don't understand why you
haven't
well because we again the home secretary
has looked to this government lawyers
that looked at this and actually we
think what we propose is in fact
entirely um you know is entirely lawful
and uh indeed of course there was a
court challenge
last week
the court upheld our right to take this
step and the reason we're doing it is
it's very important people understand
this you know we have a tragic high
number of deaths of people trying to
cross the channel and we've got people
smugglers that are exploiting that
misery and putting lives at risk and
we've got to to send a very clear signal
that
you know this this isn't something we're
going to allow to continue so as well as
yes interrupting uh those gangs we have
to make clear that they're not going to
be able to just necessarily come into
the uk that we will process some uh
in a country at a center in rwanda so
that we can actually try and stop the
demand in order to stop putting lives at
risk that's why we're doing this
what level of confidence though do you
have that that plane will take off with
more than one person on it
well look there was a legal challenge
obviously uh in respect of some of them
uh last week my understanding is that
that legal challenge fails of course
lawyers will continue you know to make
these uh
these sorts of noises but we put in
place an agreement
with rwanda i think it was um a very big
step forward when the home secretary
brittany patel secured that agreement uh
it's something actually that
the governments and oppositions have
talked about as a potential solution for
a very long time going back some 20
years and um it is it is we think the
right thing to do in order to try to
address this problem of people putting
their lives at risks uh librisk and
putting their lives in the hands of um
terrible people smugglers
um mrs i am nothing if not a man of my
word so let's talk about the food
strategy that is being launched today
and i wonder if you could speak very
directly to henry dimbleby the man whose
recommendations the government looked at
and moved forward with some of them of
course he's on the program just a little
bit later today his complaint
is twofold that half of what he
recommended has been ignored and
specifically on health clearly we know
there's an issue with obesity
particularly in adults massively in
children at the moment there's nothing
there was nothing really there on health
according to mr dimbleby how would you
respond to that
well of course i i've spoken directly to
henry henry dimbley about this in fact
we take forward the vast majority of his
recommendations and so on health and
obesity uh for instance he recommended a
data partnership that was his flagship
recommendation uh we're taking that out
because business has access to far
better consumer data than government uh
ever can and of course we've already
introduced many things in this space
we've introduced new uh requirements on
point-of-sale restrictions so that high
fat salt and sugar goods can't be uh
given prominent display in supermarkets
that is already but why not consult in
sugar tax why not the salt and sugar tax
it's clearly something that the
government has considered in the past
well um
we're already doing so we have used it
where it's appropriate where it works on
for instance um reformulation of soft
drinks where you can actually uh take
sugar out quite simply but there are
many other products like chocolate like
certain cakes where sugar is an
ingredient to those and there aren't
actually any replacements for it so we
need to look at different approaches
like maybe portion size and that's
something that we're considering and we
also
though it's important to recognize have
put in place these points of sale
restrictions that's already driving some
reformulation and it's already driving
changes in in portion size so
supermarkets are reacting to this agenda
by what we've already put in place and
of course we've put in place these
things since henry dimbleby made his
original recommendations
george it's always good to have you on
the program thanks very much for joining
us thank you very much
uh we of course began our conversation
with mr eustis there uh talking about
those gdp stats for april of course is
ed conway economics editor was saying we
had a drop of at 0.1 percent march not
0.3
at this month we've had a response um
from the man in control of the nation's
finances the chancellor of the exchequer
rishi sunac he said this at countries
around the world are seeing slowing
growth and the uk is not immune from
these challenges i want to reassure
people we're fully focused on growing
the economy to address the cost of
living in the longer term while
supporting families and businesses with
the immediate pressures they're facing
we have a plan to turbo charge
productivity says the chancellor through
investment in capital people and ideas
so everyone across the country can
benefit from a strong healthy economy he
says
let's quickly take you through the
morning's papers and we start this
morning with the financial times it
reports that the conservatives have
criticized boris johnson's attempt to
rip up the northern ireland protocol
now the guardian also leading on the
northern ireland agreement carrying a
warning from the cbi the confederation
of british industry
and the telegraph also has that story on
its front page and their headline
european judges to be stripped of
protocol powers and move away from ecj
oversight
rwanda flights may not get off the
ground the headline on the eye something
we're just speaking to the environment
secretary about the court of appeal set
later today to consider the government's
new migrant policy
well the daily mail's headline
summarizes that story with the words new
rwanda flight farce
now a former british soldier who died
fighting russian forces in ukraine has
been hailed as a hero
jordan gatley was shot and killed in the
city of svero donetsk after heading to
ukraine to help fend off russian forces
and train ukrainian soldiers
in a statement his family said his team
say they all loved him as did we and he
made a massive difference to many
people's lives not only soldiering but
also by training the ukrainian forces
jordan and his team were so proud of the
work they were doing and he often told
me that the missions they were going on
were dangerous but necessary
he loved his job and we are so proud of
him he truly was a hero
and will forever be in our hearts
speaking to sky news a friend of
jordan's said he was unique in
everything he did
i don't think he'd find a
better soldier than jordan my books to
be honest with you um
he was um
unique in everything he did
his knowledge of everything was
you know
top tier i'd say he's um
my
best friend is a bit of an
understatement you know
we were brothers
oh well intense fighting is continuing
in svera dynetsk with ukraine's
president saying his forces will defend
the city inch by inch
the region's governor has said around
500 civilians are sheltering in the
grounds of the azot chemical plant at 40
children said to be among them
at some of the days other headlines now
and police in brazil say they have found
a backpack laptop and other personal
items belonging to the british
journalist don phillips and his
colleague bruno pereira the pair went
missing a week ago in an area of the
amazon rainforest known for illegal
fishing
an industry that the pair were
investigating a colleague of mr phillips
brace based in brazil told us that hope
is running out
all the evidence is pointing towards
a terrible terrible uh outcome um it's
still a little help but it's diminishing
fast there are risks involved in going
into a place like the jivari valley it
has a reputation for illegal mining
illegal fishing
a lot of the people there have guns it's
the kind of place where journalists need
to go and find out what's really
happening otherwise areas like that
become
uh black boxes um and don phillips
um
was was trying to find a very important
story
and that's why he went there
senators in the united states have
reached a bipartisan agreement on a
limited package of measures to improve
gun safety
of course in response to last month's
mass shootings the proposals include
tougher checks on gun bars under the age
of 21
and more money from mental health and
school safety president biden welcomed
the agreement as a step in the right
direction
google has rejected the claims of one of
its engineers who said the chat bot he
was working on had become sentient blake
lemoine who has reportedly been put on
leave told the washington post the
lambda chatbot had developed the
perceptions of a child google told sky
news however hundreds of researchers and
engineers have worked with the
technology
and none of them shared lemoine's
assertions
a 12 year old boy with brain damage is
at the center of a legal row over his
future his mum says that he is still in
there the hospital treating him so his
life support should end skies sadia
chowdhury has been taking a look
archie battersby is a fighter but for
the last eight weeks after an incident
at home the 12 year old mixed martial
arts enthusiast has relied on a
mechanical ventilator to breathe
his doctors at the royal london hospital
say arch's brain stem is dead though
they haven't been able to prove that by
doing the legally accepted brain stem
test
so they've been arguing that it's most
likely that he's died
arch's mother holly says they're wrong
yeah i speak to him all the time or he's
still archie to me you know he's my
child
he's he
he just he looks like he's asleep he
doesn't
he doesn't look like an ill child um
if that makes any sense he just he still
looks angelic he's asleep you know he's
resting his little head's healing his
eyes have started to open
which again okay they're small steps but
they're still progressing in the right
direction you know and that's after sort
of like a small amount of weeks you know
if he was given a few months i think
that it could be quite different i think
we could see some significant
significant changes but these cases are
never about looks
throughout the last few weeks the high
court has heard medical evidence the
trust arguing that blood isn't flowing
to archie's brain stem and therefore
they say cells are dead or decaying a
process known as necrosis the family
argue that it's not enough for just a
part of the brain to be dead when other
parts are working and when the heart is
still beating they want the criminal
standard of proof to be applied here
that is for the trust to prove its
theory beyond reasonable doubt that
archie has died
holly says her son is showing signs of
recovery and that this video shows him
gripping her fingers
doctors say it's just friction
they say nurses are experiencing moral
distress at the prospect of
resuscitating the youngster in what they
say is the certain eventuality of his
having cardiac arrest
but this case wasn't about the nurses or
indeed the family the judge must decide
today what is in archie's best interest
sadia chowdhury sky news at the high
court in london
now an australian newspaper has denied
outing the actor rebel wilson as it
faces outcry over supporting on her new
relationship with a woman
uh the bridesmaid star shared a photo of
herself with uh ramona gruma on
instagram not that photo obviously
saying i thought i was searching for a
disney prince but maybe what i needed
all of this time
was a disney princess with a hashtag
love is love
but in a story published by the sydney
morning herald the columnist andrew
hornery described how rebel wilson had
supposedly ignored his requests for
comment about the relationship earlier
that week and instead revealed her own
news herself
heaven for friend time for the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar
airways i'm reliably informed that
atlantic frontal systems will threaten
northwestern parts of the country over
the next few days whilst the high
pressure building in the south will
bring more settled conditions and
increasing temperatures from midweek
onwards at this morning chilly start in
the south plenty of sunshine and the
north will see more extensive cloud with
showers and patchy outbreaks of rain
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
let me remind you of a promise that a
rather famous face made in a song many
many years ago
[Music]
that's how we all dressed back then uh
robbie williams is going back on tour
across the uk and ireland this autumn
marking 25 years a quarter of a century
can you believe it since he began his
solo career started off with the boy
band take that left the group in the
summer of 1995 to go solo and of course
now one of the world's most decorated
artists having recorded 13 uk number one
albums 13. can you believe it a quick
reminder as to our top stories this
morning new figures show the economy has
shrunk for the second month in a row
with gross domestic profit and gross
domestic profit falling by 0.3
in april
the government is to publish legislation
which would allow ministers to overwrite
parts of the brexit agreement with the
eu on northern ireland
an appeal hearing is expected to take
place today after the high court gave
the go-ahead for the first flight
removing asylum seekers to be processed
in rwanda
but before all of that a government
minister has told the program there are
real challenges ahead as new figures
show that the economy shrank in april
the environment secretary george eustis
said the figure's showing uh that gross
gross domestic product was down what a
reminder of those challenges
and the truth is that as we all come out
of the pandemic globally there are
pressures on supply chains and a lot of
inflationary pressure around the world
principally of course caused by that
spike in the gas price so we've known
for some time that this is going to be a
challenge but it doesn't take away from
the fact that actually we were
successful at getting ourselves through
the pandemic the fastest vaccine roll
out and that put our economy in a strong
position to recover we've got
unemployment that's at record lows the
lowest it's been since at least 1974 but
of course there are some real challenges
ahead and and these gdp figures of
course are a reminder of those
challenges
our political correspondent ali forte's
cute is in the studio morning early um i
mean he's not wrong i mean
lots of countries have lots of problems
but i've lost count of the number of
times i've been told by government
ministers that our economy was performed
brilliantly perhaps even better than the
rest of the g7 clearly not yeah and the
oecd figures on the weekend show that
we're going to have the slowest growth
of any developed economy next year so i
think you know the the economic backdrop
is obviously bad we've got the prime
minister on this big domestic agenda
blitz we expect there's gonna be a
speech with the chancellor what he's
facing a lot of pressure on is tax cuts
that was something that the oecd um did
mention as being part of the problem
people like jake berry prominent
backbencher saying that tax cuts would
be an important way of cracking on with
levelling up but he sounded quite sort
of fiscally conservative
a couple of days ago when he was making
that speech about housing saying we
can't spend our way out of this problem
remember um the chancellor just
announced something about 21 billion
pounds to help people with the cost of
living so i think the government is
going to face pressure when it comes to
things like tax cuts
but yeah more bleak warnings today and
i'm afraid every time we go to our
economics editor conway it feels like
he's got some more bad news for us
certainly does we've got the cbi's chief
economist on later on as well so we'll
find out what they're thinking for now
ali thanks very much
indeed abbott
bringing you a little bit more now on
government plans to override parts of
the brexit agreement set to be published
a little later today i'm joined now uh
by the former permanent secretary at the
department for exiting the european
union philip rydcliffe philip great to
have you in the program this morning um
look clearly we are waiting for the bill
to be tabled and until it has been we
don't know the full details uh of what
will be in it but from your reading
of what has been
sourced to the newspapers leaked to the
newspapers
is this a breach of our international
commitments
well it has been heavily trialled and
expect to hear a lot today about red
channels and green channels and dual
regulatory
environments about b.a.t rules about the
role of the european court of justice
this isn't a modest tinkering with the
protocol this effectively
seeks to give the uk government
leeway to remove any aspect of the
protocol
that it doesn't like so it effectively
guts the protocol the government says
and brandon lewis the central state for
northern ireland was
on the news yesterday said oh yes this
respects international law i suspect
that claim will be uh greeted with some
doubt uh by many outside of government
and will be very vigorously challenged
both within our own parliament but also
by the european commission and others
internationally
yeah i mean it's been donkey's years
since i studied public international law
but my reading of events seems to be
that the government is suggesting that
because in their view the european union
is not negotiating in good faith they're
not acting in good faith that gives them
the opportunity under the withdrawal
agreement under the northern ireland
protocol to go back to square one
well that that is uh an interpretation i
think the the common sense
interpretation of this would say
you signed up to a deal um not very long
ago
in good faith there are mechanisms to
resolve disputes within that deal and
but what you choose to do instead is to
is to rewrite the deal unilaterally now
if that approach was taken uh to
international deals generally that would
essentially be the end of the
international order the uk
let's not forget is a country that is
seeking to position itself uh as an
international leader and upholding the
respect for the rule of law so this is
not a good look there will be legal
arguments around it but i'll say the
common sense few would say that this is
not the sort of approach uh that a
country that is seeking international
respect that should take to its
international obligations
so so what then will be the response um
from the european union to all of this i
mean you could hardly describe ourselves
as a sleepwalking given that we're
discussing on television but are we
perhaps marching towards a trade war
with our hands over our eyes a little
bit
well that that is the that is the risk
so the european commission today won't
throw his toys out of the pram it will
uh seek to demonstrate that it is the
adults in in the room so it will take a
measured response today but it will be
very very clear that if the uk
progresses with this that the european
commission european union will take
appropriate action that can be modulated
over time it won't happen overnight
but at the end of the day if this if
this is carried through and the uk uh
pushes
this to the extent of essentially to
supply the protocol then there is a risk
of a full-blown trade war with the eu
which would result um in the eu
withdrawing from the uh not just from
the protocol but from the whole
trade and corporation agreement and
given the state of the uk economy
frankly that's the last thing we need
and it's not just uh that eventuality in
in the months to come it's the
uncertainty in the run-up to that and
that uncertainty hitting not just
businesses in northern ireland but
across the rest of the uk as well one of
the things that's happened since brexit
is investment levels in the uk economy
have lagged behind where they should be
and it is investment decisions in
particular that will be infected by that
uncertainty
philip rycroft great to have you on the
program thanks for joining us
thank you
uh well let's stick shall we with those
planned changes to the novel northern
ireland protocol try saying that seven
o'clock in monday morning i'm joined now
by the chief executive of manufacturing
northern ireland stephen kelly stephen
good to see you this morning um so so
what do you make of it of course again
as i said to phillip rycroft a couple of
minutes ago we are waiting to see the
full text of the bill when it is laid
before the house a little bit later on
today but on the basis of what you have
seen is this the type of action that the
government should be taking right now
well it's not the business community in
northern ireland has come together
like never before
we've been working very diligently with
both the uk
and the negotiators
uh and we believe that a negotiated
outcome is still possible
and then anything that
perhaps triggers that
opportunity is
really suboptimal and the reality for
businesses here in northern ireland is
largely 2021 was the year that the
protocol caused most offense
and 2022 they're getting on with the
challenges of business today
there's opportunities here in the
protocol for many sectors as has been
evidenced by our increase in exports and
the growth in jobs and we want to make
sure that the the benefits the protocol
are not through night
when the uk government is trying to take
this
action through the parliament
stephen when so many businesses in
northern ireland are reporting a
negative impact on their bottom line as
a as a result of you know the the the
actions taken under the northern ireland
protocol and as we've been in this
transition period when so many people
are reporting such a negative impact why
are there so few people who who are
minded uh to stand shoulder to shoulder
with the government and go back to to
square one to rip up the agreement that
they signed
well there aren't so many businesses
that are having that negative impact
there are a number of businesses there
are a number of sectors that have an
impact more than others but just take
the manufacturing community 80 percent
are saying that the protocol
is a benefit and an opportunity for them
same numbers come out from the northern
chamber of commerce so the the narrative
that appears certainly in in parliament
and perhaps across some of the media and
the rest of the uk is that the protocol
is really damaging but the reality is
somewhat different
and what we need neil is that the
negotiators need to spend the time now
this bill is in parliament from 3 30
today
uh the uk and the eu you need to spend
the time that that bill has taken its
passage through parliament to sit down
and actually negotiate
uh they should involve the business
community actually understand how goods
are moved not just across the arc but
across the rest
of europe as well there's an opportunity
here for northern ireland
excuse me there's an opportunity here
for northern ireland
uh that will build our prosperity and
then return cement our peace and
anything that potentially undermines
that
by taking unilateral action is
suboptimal in our view and we want to
make sure that
whatever we end up with come the end of
the summer or come the end of this year
is something that we can build upon and
really grow the northern ireland economy
um stephen clearly and did you mention
that yourself a moment ago i mean you
are you are closer to to the two
negotiating teams that than i will be i
however speak quite regularly publicly
and you know
and privately to people within and
around government and they are
consistently saying to me at the moment
that in terms of negotiating with the
european commission
the eu is acting in bad faith what is
your view of that
i wouldn't agree that they're acting in
bad faith but i would certainly agree
that uh they've really sat on their
hands for a number of months now they
took an assessment perhaps back in
february
uh that they wanted to wait until the
northern assembly elections were
complete and see where the cards fell in
terms of our parliament
i think that was a mistake i i think
that the
eu really should have been using the
period from march until
june to negotiate
maybe if one thing good comes out of the
lane of this legislation today in this
bill today is that the eu will kick into
action
certainly the ideas are there in terms
of resolving these issues the eu are
closer on customs than we were this time
last year uh we're nowhere at all at
this point in time on the issue of what
they call sps
so hopefully if
this bill does one thing it actually
brings an attention and focus not just
in brussels but across eu capitals
this issue needs to be resolved they
need to reach and stretch their place
that's probably not visible to them
just now and if we do that we can
actually create the conditions that will
allow everybody in northern ireland to
enjoy the benefits of the protocol
stephen kelly manufacturing northern
ireland thank you so much for joining us
this morning good to see you
let's return to our discussions around
ukraine and ukrainian police continue to
investigate the actions of russian
troops well in the early days of the
invasion at the end of february kremlin
forces were trying to enter the capital
and killed many people most of them
civilians as they tried to escape
it's believed the russian soldiers
burned a lot of the cars
with the people they'd killed still in
sight
thousands of ukrainians used the m06
highway which runs west of kiev to flee
the russian advance from there our chief
correspondent stuart ramsey reports
they've rebuilt the bridge now the
motorway traffic to the west of kiev
looks normal
but when the history of this war is
written a chapter will be saved for the
m06 and the e40 highway
killing ground for russian soldiers that
ukraine will never forget
the police say the attacks on civilians
along this road lasted from february
28th to about the end of the first week
of march
they've saved the cars that were shot up
by the russians in a series of breakers
yards
most are burnt out but many are as they
were
the possessions of the families still
inside
the blood on the seats is dry now
the bullet holes are cold
well this um
these cars are all part of an
investigation into what happened on
the main
road that takes you into the west
of kiev that's the m06
and the e40
these are mainly almost exclusively
being driven by uh civilians
many of them were hit by
tank rounds
set on fire
or just
shot up
we know that a man we're not certain
which car but one of these a man
was
killed and this video showing him
dead on the side of the road this is a
family vehicle
you can see inside we know that large
numbers of families uh were
shot and and many of them killed as they
tried to escape
as the war uh got nearer and this is the
car i was driving in as well
um
we
five of us got out of this i i submit
it's
quite amazing uh really i got out this
side but everywhere we had been
um
this bullet uh holes in in in the seats
etc
uh also up in the in the in the roof it
was a professional hit the
the police certainly no doubt about that
what's interesting is what the soldiers
will tell you is the grouping of the
bullets so the first sets
of bullets were to try to kill the
driver which would be these ones uh to
the right
and then
uh left to the passenger seat and then
slightly across and you can see we would
probably certainly richie mukler our
cameraman who was in the front was
pretty much saved by the engine block
which took
quite a lot
of the rounds
in the days that followed the attack on
us police say 20 people were killed on
the same short stretch of road
locals filmed this vehicle as it was set
on fire
it belonged to a family they knew had
been trying to get away
they were shot at by russian soldiers
sohei stotsky and his baby daughter anna
were injured but survived and were
allowed to leave by the russians after
pleading with them
so his wife lena was killed immediately
and witnesses say her body burnt in the
car
she was just 28 years old
i have a reason to live and i try to
recover as fast as possible just because
i have a small child and they need to
protect her
because i couldn't protect my wife
and you know i feel guilty about this
the war is far from over of course for
now it's moved to the east but it could
easily return
the locations and the memorials aren't
part of history yet
we're still on the first draft
still ramsey sky news keith
and more from stuart and the team on the
website but now mcdonald's remember them
they've reopened their doors in russia
but under a new name
the company pulled out of the country
when of course sanctions were imposed
over russia's invasion of ukraine 15
branches were bought by a russian
businessman and they began serving big
queues on sunday under their new name
vocusnow and tochka which translates as
tasty and that's it
yeah not so sure the mcdonald's will be
panicking terribly about this one
but let's remain talking about the
economy and as we've seen this morning
the outlook is looking
increasingly bleak for the uk and the
cbr the confederation of british
industry has significantly downgraded
their forecasts for growth for the
remainder of this year and the next uh
we're joined now uh by the chief
economist at the cbi rayne newton smith
rayne great to have you on the program
this morning of course
along with europeans this morning we've
also had the gdp we've also had gdp
figures out not 0.3 contraction in april
not quite what people were necessarily
expecting rin
yeah we're still seeing a weak economic
outlook at the moment and
we do think the economy as a whole will
grow this year
so we'll grow by about 3.7 percent this
year
but then we should see growth of only 1
next year and i think look
we have seen a contraction on the month
in gdp and the latest figures and i
think what is clear because of the high
inflation we're seeing here
in the uk
for many households this year it will
feel like a recession we're going to see
the biggest squeeze on household incomes
we expect since records uh began and as
a consequence of that
consumption household spending is likely
to shrink every quarter for the next
four quarters and that's why it's so
important that we keep business
investment going and flowing throughout
our economy so that we can see that
return to growth and productivity and
increasing living standards here in the
uk which i think we all want to see
we've had the environment secretary on
the program this morning when asked
about those figures his view was pretty
close to that of the chancellor of the
exchequer you know countries around the
world are seeing slowing growth the uk
is not immune from those challenges
essentially saying look we've all got to
kind of grin and bear i mean to what
extent is that true
i mean look as we've seen in just that
report we're showing us now the
devastating war in the ukraine is having
economic consequences here though of
course our thoughts are immediately with
the devastating human toll that it's
having but yes we've seen rising global
energy prices rising global commodity
prices and that is creating headwinds
for so many uh economies so yes it's
partly about global factors that are
pushing up uh inflation but i think it's
wrong to say there isn't things the
government here can do we've already
seen the chancellor act to help support
the most vulnerable households in our
society but there's much more he could
be doing now to help get business
investment going next year he's been
bold in having a super deduction that's
an incentive to really bring forward
an increased business investment but
that comes to an end next year and
that's exactly when we need to see the
engine of growth uh continuing here in
the uk so we need to see a permanent
investment allowance and we should see
the government accelerating our
transition to a net zero economy now is
the time to really be investing in
renewable energy and making our homes
warmer more energy efficient the
government have had some amount some
programs to help uh vulnerable
households make their homes more energy
efficient but we need we haven't seen
the latest round of that we could
absolutely be accelerating what we're
doing now to get on with delivering
growth in this country i mean i suppose
then from what you're saying rain that
the last thing we really want right now
is a trade war with the european union
something that a few people are
suggesting you know could result from
the changes that we're making to the
northern ireland protocol where do you
fall in that
look we need both sides to absolutely
stay at the table we need a negotiated
outcome the northern ireland protocol is
is working on the ground but it can
absolutely be improved and so for that
we need both sides to stay
at the table we need flexibility from
both sides unilateral action from either
sites is really not going to help we
don't need the uk to walk away from this
but we do need to see more flexibility
from the european side we absolutely
need to ensure we have a good trading
agreement with our biggest trading
partner
i mean
are you perhaps frustrated
at the chancellor and others in
whitehall at the moment then right
i think what we're asking for is to see
the same uh commitment and energy and
with getting growth going in our economy
as we saw during cobit we've seen the
chancellor be bold before and he has
acted to support vulnerable households
in this latest crisis but i think we
want to see that spirit from across
government to really get on with the
things that are under their uh control i
don't think now is the time to play
politics we need to see the focus on
action on policies that will deliver for
businesses and households throughout the
economy
newton smith the cbi lovely to have you
on the program this morning take care
thank you
now let's take you through some of the
best pictures making the papers today
uh here's the guardian the old and the
new uh they've got a picture of the 74
criteria on the dauphine cycle race
passing a horse rider uh in the hot
suave in france uh the old
becoming the new uh the telegraph has
this shot
of paul on the right there and the mini
cooper s which took part in the 1986
monte carlo rally and has been restored
as you can see it's former glory uh by
neville chap on the left there the pair
took the many down to the new forest for
the 40th national mini day and finally
the old with the o the time says this
fantastic shot of a hurricane and a
spitfire from the battle of britain
memorial flight at t site on saturday